so what does fire prevention week have
to do with driving well when it comes to
wildfires the Nevada Department of
Transportation and others have some
creative answers
from a simple Instagram message equip
off-road vehicles with spark arrestors
to a Nevada fire info video about
trailer safety chains these are used in
the event that the hitch comes off of
the ball and these will actually catch
the trailer for us and keep it connected
to the vehicle sometimes there's too
much slack and these are dragging on the
ground causing potentially dangerous
Sparks and a different kind of fire
prevention from a Maverick Adventure
video
[Music]
remember your ATV exhaust system can get
hotter than a thousand degrees never
Park your vehicle over brush your grass
like that spark safety not wildfires
all right so fire prevention does
include driving safely with motorcycles
trailers and off-road vehicles buckle up
drive carefully please put down that
phone you can join the driving to Crazy
conversation at traffic eight at
eightnewsnow.com